[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today this
question comes from Irene in Texas
hey yeah I like that she says this is
probably a long shot in reaching out
since I'm sure everyone does but I'm
pretty much drowning in debt as
embarrassing as it is to say that I'm
handling my credit cards car and private
student loans using your methods as best
as I can but when it comes to federal
student loans my anxiety kicks in
especially now that the payments will
restart again and by the way interest
starts today I have about 192 000 an
astronomical amount in interest as is
part of that sum in student loans and I
don't know where to get the correct info
on how to pay it I feel like everyone
has a different take and it's hard to
know what move to make so that I don't
add any more to the debt any help on how
to move forward with this is greatly
appreciated I just can't afford 2K
payments every month which is probably
what they will want me to pay all right
John let's let's get comfortable right
here because
we're going to unpack this number one
Irene you're not alone that's the first
thing I want you to understand here is
thank you for this question because you
asking this is about to give Solutions
and answers for a lot of people so thank
you so much for that
um 192 000 in federal student loans plus
other debt obviously you guys know
interest starts today with payment
starting
um in October whenever your payment is
due in October and she's going to be one
of those people so there's a lot of
misinformation out there and it can be
confusing okay Irene so the first thing
I want you to do and this for anybody
listening you need to find who's got
your loan okay because most of the loan
providers that were out there before
kovid they've decided student loan
business sucks we're out and so your
loan has been sold to somebody else all
right so you need to find who that is
whether it's moella whether it's uh
Granite State or whatever that one is
called Great Lakes all of these
different ones it's no longer Sallie Mae
right there's all these other service
providers so you need to
answer your correspondence right if
you're getting letters in the mail if
you're getting emails like don't bury
your head in the sand open that bad boy
up and see what's going on call the
1-800 number and I posted about this on
social the other day yeah you might be
on hold for a minute and this might take
a couple of lunch breaks to get this
thing done but uh Don't Tap Out simply
because it's taking longer than you
hoped you need to find out what's going
on all right next part to that is you're
going to talk to a student loan rep and
they're going to act like they know
what's best for you and I'm telling you
right now they are a customer service
expert they are not a finance or money
expert okay and I can tell you this they
barely understand what's going on okay
so when they start saying oh we could do
a an icr planner an ibr plan or a save
planner and they start saying all these
things they're going to suggest the one
that they know the most about okay not
what's necessarily best for you so
A1 is I want you to be able to make your
payment okay so when you open up that
envelope or you log into the screen and
you go oh 221 I can do that if you can
do it great keep it like that if you
look at that payment and you're like
holy crap if I do that we don't get to
eat now is the time to start thinking
about okay how can I make this minimum
payment lower all right so that that's
the only time if it's keeping you from
eating
lower your payment and get a smaller
minimum temporarily now in this case
with Irene hold on that means some
people are going to have to sell their
house because they bought a house two or
three years ago and they owed three
hundred thousand dollars and they
thought that was all going to go away
and it didn't yeah that means some
people have to move Apartments what
you're saying is not if you're gonna
have to adjust your lifestyle a lot then
see if you can lower the payment no no
no yes you want the payment as high as
you can possibly get it or you can still
make that payment well there's a there's
a piece to that John so if you're if
you're working a debt snowball like
Irene or like Sam and I for instance and
you've got a bunch of other debts in
your student loans like it's interesting
because her her payments are two
thousand dollars my husband and I our
student loan payments alone or two
thousand dollars we could not make those
payments even with a Bare Bones budget
so what we did in the only way the only
only in Big Red Letters bold underline
with lots of exclamation points okay
hear me on this the only way I would
entertain a payment plan to lower my
minimum payment is if I'm intensely
working a debt snowball because in the
debt snowball if anybody doesn't
understand this you're listing all of
your debts smallest to largest you're
making minimum payments on everything
and then your extra money you need extra
money to throw out the smallest debt now
in the midst of this you're working
extra jobs you are not going out to eat
you are not having a life because you're
paying off your debt and if that can
help you get leverage the same way we
say hey lower your uh your withholding
you know so you're not getting a tax
return so you have extra money the same
way we say hey temporarily pause your
401k contribution to get extra money all
of this stuff all of this guidance is
contingent upon you doing the plan
because if you're going to lollygag and
you're gonna kick rocks and be like well
you know I'll do a little here a little
there then you pausing your retirement
you're screwing yourself you doing an
IDR plan you're screwing yourself you
have to do this with the intent of I am
paying off my debt and I'm doing this
with intensity and intentionality and it
is not simply to Kick the Can down the
road and hope that 20 to 25 years from
now there's some kind of you know bucket
of forgiveness so
and how am I supposed to just not go out
then yes yes oh am I supposed to just go
like for hikes with on with the person
I'm dating yes yeah
that's all you can afford that's all you
can afford because at the end of the day
um Irene when it comes to this you get
on the phone you talk to this person
they're gonna say hey why don't you do
this plan why don't you do that plan or
by the way here's the newest thing uh 12
month on ramp
12 month on-ramp says Hey when payments
resume in October if you're not ready to
pay don't pay
and will allow the interest to accrue
yes because we're going to get our money
because again
federal student loans they want your
payment they don't want your piece okay
so they're gonna let that interest
accrue but oh how nice of them we just
won't tell the credit bureau that you're
defaulting so we're just not going to
report it and for a year you can go on
and let that interest accrue as though
we're doing you a favor it's like a
medical doctor saying you know what
we're just gonna keep taking your blood
tests and putting them in a shredder for
a year you eat however you want to do
what you smoke whatever you want drink
whatever you want it's all good we're
just gonna put your blood test you're
still gonna die you're still gonna die
you're still gonna die and let me tell
you guys something because
I don't think John people I don't think
their brain and their heart and their
mind will let them accept the fact that
they can be free
you can pay off these student loans it's
not a myth it's not mythical what Irene
is talking about I know that situation
my husband and I had 280 000 of student
loans part of them were federal student
loans a big chunk and a big chunk were
private variable interest rates okay
like I said before one of the loans was
192 thousand dollars and the payment on
it was nine hundred dollars on that one
loan I'm getting choked up just talking
about it because I know how that mess
feels so don't wait around you have to
be free I don't care if they tell you
the interest is not accruing if they
tell you well forgive it after 25 years
your body feels that mess your marriage
feels that she says my anxiety kicks in
it should it should that's your body
telling you you're not safe because
you're not because you're not
and I've lived it too man Sheila my wife
we've both lived it
say that again
ex like um I think we say peace a lot
and I don't even know that we have a
psychology for that anymore yeah
walk people through the back end of this
like what it actually feels like when
there's all this tussling going into
Washington and you just you just keep
swiping because it doesn't it doesn't
apply to you yeah look the goal is to
get above the radar right where you're
just flying above you're like an eagle
man you you're looking and you're going
what's going on down there oh man okay
I'm glad I don't have nothing to do with
that that's what it is on the other side
of this on the other side of Freedom you
have forgiveness for yourself
for yourself because so many of you guys
feel like man I can't believe I let the
government trick me I got swindled into
this and it's like man was I was I
seriously that dumb no you weren't you
made a bad choice but when you pay off
your debt you get forgiveness and you
get peace and you get Freedom with your
money that's what this is all about not
waiting for somebody to be a hero you're
your own hero go get your freedom get it
out get your piece get it Irene in the
Republic of Texas make it happen